you of course her co-stars of Jennifer
Garner the cover girl of this month is
you have you read the article I haven't
I've seen snippets and I talked to her
yesterday sorry yesterday and she's so
happy about it and it's a beautiful
beautiful cover and I'm just thrilled
that they are that Vanity Fair is
honoring her how is she doing Jennifer
is she Wallace she's good I think she's
doing really well I mean she's you know
dealing with a lot of stress and pain
and and dealing with it and I think in a
magnificent way it was also amazing a
lovely to see how open she was and
sharing her story and the magazine and
discussing everything that happened and
how she's planning to proceed what did
you think
well I've always found her to be
incredibly authentic it's part of why
people I think are drawn to her because
she is she's she is real and and she
also has a great capacity for love and
that and and you know her children are
her passion and so all that said she's
she's dealing with the situation
I think miraculously and it has been
write the article so you know how she
doing I I imagine he has but I haven't I
saw him but I haven't talked to him
about it so I'm hoping he's okay I think
it was handled very respectfully
well she's nothing if not respectful and
she and also there's still great love
between them